Hallo zusammen,
das sind eure Kommentare
zur Reportage
"Psychopharmaka für Hunde? -
Therapie gegen Angst
und Aggressionen".
Gleich vorneweg: Es ist der 14. Juni,
es ist Frauenstreik
und wir sind direkt am Helvetiaplatz.
Wenn ihr also ab und zu ein Megafon
oder Musik hört, kommt das von dort.
Nun geht es jedoch um Hunde,
um psychisch kranke Hunde,
um Psychopharmaka
und um eure Kommentare dazu.
In vielen Kommentaren
geht es ums Pro und Kontra
zu Psychopharmaka.
Daher möchte ich mit der Fachfrau
Maya Bräm sprechen.
Sie ist Verhaltensmedizinerin
und gerade an einem Kongress
in Deutschland.
Mit ihr schaue ich mir
einige eurer Kommentare an.
Hallo, Maya.
- Hallo.
Hoi.
Ich las die Kommentare bewusst
nicht, weil ich dachte ...
Du hast sie bewusst nicht gelesen?
- Ja, weil ich dachte ...
Diese Entrüstung ist typisch.
Sie begegnet mir häufig.
Das ist zu erwarten.
Darf ich dir
zwei Kommentare vorlesen?- Klar.
Ich lese sie dir kurz vor.
Jessy B. schreibt z.B.:
Ursula Schenkfelder schreibt:
Wie kannst du dir erklären,
dass die meisten Kommentare
in diese Richtung gingen?
Das ist zu erwarten.
Das begegnet einem immer wieder,
wenn man
mit Psychopharmaka arbeitet.
Erstens ist es nicht die erste Wahl.
Es wird nur dort eingesetzt,
wo es indiziert ist,
und als Teil des Ganzen.
Ich glaube, viele der Kommentare
erklären sich durch das Unwissen,
was Psychopharmaka bewirken
und was der Sinn davon ist.
Es ist nicht das Ziel, ein Tier oder
einen Menschen damit vollzupumpen.
Es ist nicht das Ziel,
sie lahmzulegen,
sondern ihnen zu helfen, besser
mit der Umwelt umgehen zu können.
Es gibt bestimmt Hunde,
bei denen es sich um ein reines
Erziehungsproblem handelt.
Galeno ist ein solches Beispiel.
Er ist ein junger Hund,
der vieles nicht kannte.
Das braucht einfach Zeit.
In diesem Fall
wäre es total kontraproduktiv
und kontraindiziert,
Psychopharmaka einzusetzen.
Es muss auch
nicht immer ein Trauma sein.
Bei Hunden gibt es
auch genetische Veranlagungen.
Ich behandle Hunde,
die von Züchtern, aus dem Ausland,
von Bauernhöfen
oder von Hobbyzüchtern stammen.
Es kann quasi jeden treffen.
Es ist wichtig, dass man nicht
über sie und ihre Besitzer urteilt.
Es ist ganz schwierig
für die Besitzer, wenn es heisst:
"Erzieht doch einfach euren Hund"
oder "Beschäftigt ihn mehr".
Meistens
sind die Besitzer auch am Anschlag
und haben schon sehr viel probiert.
Auch die Wirksamkeit
von Psychopharmaka
wurde immer wieder angefochten.
Oliver Wigger schreibt z.B.:
Andere schreiben,
dass sie nichts nützen.
In der Reportage
zitierte ich nur eine Studie.
Wie sieht die wissenschaftliche Lage
zur Wirksamkeit von Psychopharmaka
aus?
Es gibt auch bei Tieren
viele Studien zur Wirksamkeit
von Psychopharmaka -
sowohl zu kurzfristig als auch lang-
fristig einsetzbaren Medikamenten.
Es gibt Erfahrungswerte,
die belegen, dass sie helfen können.
Sina und Maya sind
zwei Erfahrungsbeispiele dafür,
dass sie helfen können.
Aber es gibt keine Garantie, dass
sie bei einem bestimmten Individuum
so wirken,
wie es die Wissenschaft sagt.
Es gingen
auch noch andere Kommentare ein.
Ich lese mal einen davon vor.
Maria Mandingorra schreibt:
Denkst du, dass wir in zehn Jahren
an einem anderen Punkt sein werden?
Werden sich die Menschen
dann vermehrt bewusst sein,
dass Tiere auch eine Psyche haben?
Ja, ich hoffe sehr,
dass wir auf dem Weg dazu sind.
Ich mache weiter.
Der nächste Kommentar
ist auch etwas an mich gerichtet
und etwas provokant.
Nostromo schreibt:
Ist da etwas dran?
Haben zu viele Menschen einen Hund?
Ein Problem ist vielleicht,
dass sich viele
unüberlegt ein Tier anschaffen.
Aber das könnte sich auch
auf Gebiete ausserhalb
des Tierreichs ausweiten.
Vielleicht bin ich nicht die rich-
tige Person, um das zu beurteilen.
Denn ich sehe immer die Fälle,
in denen es schiefgeht.
Die vielen Hunde,
denen es gut geht, sehe ich nicht.
Ich denke,
es gibt viele Hundehalter -
meine Klienten mit eingeschlossen -
die ihre Sache gut machen.
Die meisten Aussenstehenden, die mich
mit dem viermonatigen Galeno sahen,
hätten wahrscheinlich gesagt: "Du
hättest keinen Hund haben sollen."
Wenn sie mich dagegen
jetzt mit Galeno sehen, sagen alle:
"Wow, du bist der geborene Hündeler.
Das passt total zu dir."
Es ist auch eine Momentaufnahme.
Man urteilt sehr schnell, ohne
die Geschichte dahinter zu kennen -
insbesondere
bei Hunden oder Kindern,
die sich nicht richtig verhalten.
Ich möchte noch
ein letztes Thema ansprechen:
Es gab zwei Kommentare, die sich
auf den Fall der Hündin Sina bezogen.
Vanessa Kohler schreibt:
Meine erste Reaktion war:
"Ja, vielleicht."
"Das kann sein."
Bei Sina war sicher
auch eine Schmerzkomponente dabei,
die auf der Strasse nicht weg wäre.
Aber Sina wurde ja aus einer
Tötungsstation gerettet.- Genau.
Dort wäre es ihr
nicht besser gegangen.
Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass
sie in der Tötungsstation landete,
weil es auf der Strasse ein Problem
gab oder weil es eine Säuberungs...
Oder sind
diese Säuberungsaktionen ein Mythos?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich war nie vor Ort.
Einigen Individuen
geht es auf der Strasse gut
und sie kommen mit
dem zivilisierten Leben nicht klar.
Anderen dagegen geht es viel besser,
weil sie nicht mehr ständig Futter
suchen, sich verteidigen müssen
oder von Ladenbesitzern
weggescheucht werden.
Körperlich gesünder
sind sie bestimmt,
wenn sie
nicht auf der Strasse leben.
Danke. Einen guten Kongress.
- Ich danke dir.
Tschüss, Maya.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2023